the news has been rough in the world of
spider-man in the days since it was
reported that Disney and Sony were going
their separate ways
unable to reach an agreement regarding
their joint partnership over the
spider-man franchise many have been
playing the blame game and firing shots
at both studios thanks to a new report
from variety breaking down the
spider-man splits we may finally know
who to point their fingers at according
to an unnamed source with inside
knowledge of the deal the x-men
franchise may be to blame for Disney and
Sony divorcing The Insider noted that
Disney walked away from negotiations
partly because executives want Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige to places
focused more on the Marvel properties
the studio recently acquired from box
those properties include the x-men the
Fantastic Four and many others shortly
before Disney acquired most of Fox's
assets in March 2019 when the two
companies merged under a seventy 1.3
billion dollar deal it was confirmed
that [ __ ] would be taking over the
x-men movie franchise and already had
ideas as to what he was going to do with
the gang of mutants within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe namely he wants to
recast Wolverine with a younger actor
and evidently start things over from
square one longtime x-men producer
Lauren Shuler Donner who hired by ghee
is an associate producer on 2000 x-men
stated to deadline in February 2009 teen
that Feige was quote still dealing with
the wealth of characters and trying to
make sense of it all Mikey's plan for
the x-men property reportedly became
much clearer in June 2019 following the
release of Dark Phoenix the 12th entry
in the x-men movie series a financial
and critical failure dark being exposed
to the lowest opening weekend of any
x-men movie in history and is considered
by some to be the worst installment to
the franchise which is disappointing
given that it was the last ever x-men
film produced by Fox reportedly dark
Phoenix's box office bombings spurred
Disney brass to rework its priorities at
Marvel Studios evidently wanted Feige to
focus on rebuilding the x-men brand a
source close to variety indicated that
Walt Disney Studios co-chairman Alan
Bergman insisted on an end to the Sony
talks after Dark Phoenix blocked though
it's tempting to jump on the x-men
killed spider-man train fans should take
this report with a grain of salt no one
but the parties involved in the Disney
Sony split know what really happened and
plenty of rumors have surfaced in the
time since the
News broke some claim that Disney and
Sony are secretly working things out
behind the scenes while others are
convinced that what's done is done and
there's no turning back at this point in
time it's anyone's guess what's coming
next
even with Feige and spider-man actor Tom
Holland having recently addressed the
situation during the 2019 d23 Expo in
late August the men spoke with
Entertainment Weekly about the studio's
breakup and Spidey's MCU exit howl and
express gratitude for getting to play
spider-man for what he called five
amazing years with the character while
buggies stated that the deal between
Disney and Sony was quote never meant to
last forever my parents are dead it's
interesting to consider Dark Phoenix in
the future of the x-men franchise being
a major force behind Disney's decision
to walk away from the negotiating table
and let Sony regain sole ownership over
spider-man Holland's web slinging hero
has proven wildly successful for both
studios with many fans and critics
agreeing that his iteration of
spider-man is the best one yet the most
recent franchise entry
spider-man far from home earned over a
billion dollars worldwide becomes Sony's
top earning movie ever one could argue
that it makes little sense that Disney
and Marvel would prioritize fixing a
broken franchise over keeping a really
good thing going either way if the
studio's really have split it's hard not
to be worried about the fate of that
third Tom Hollands star in spider-man
movie well at least we can all agree
that third one's always the worst
however it doesn't seem totally
unreasonable that by game company would
want to end the ongoing tug of war with
Sony / spider-man and instead focus
their time and expertise on building the
x-men film series back up the spider-man
movies clearly aren't hurting for
attention in any aspect and thanks to
pikeys inputs are on the steadiest
ground they've been on since Sam Raimi's
original trilogy it seems that the
biggest takeaway from all the Spidey
related news is this Sony will probably
be fine Disney and Marvel will probably
be fine and both studios will hopefully
be able to coexist in peace College
spider-man isn't going anywhere in the
immediate future and neither are the
fans of the franchise for now at least
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
spider-man are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]